je tenais à dire une forme de
satisfaction d'être
auditionné en tant qu organisation
représentative des agents sur des sujets
qui parfois nous laisse un peu de côté
c'est un peu ce qui fera le
le sujet de ces quelques mots que je
vais dire la question du recours aux au
cabinet de consultants
je ne sais pas si il ya plus ou moins de
recours
sur le long terme en tout cas c'est un
sujet
qui remonte déjà à quelques années et
qui arrive un peu sur le devant de la
scène si j'ose dire
dans les années 2000 avec notamment la
création d'une direction qui a suscité
un peu des commentaires la direction
générale de la modernisation de l'état
qui en faisait une espèce de deux portes
d'entrée des consultants au coeur même
de l'administration de l'état et de
bercy
on a aussi
assisté dans cette même période à une
sorte de disqualification de la parole
des organisations représentatives des
personnels et du coup des fonctionnaires
dans leur ensemble à une époque où un
premier ministre même si c'était
peut-être une maladresse je n'en sais
rien mais avait parlé des fonctionnaires
comme de moules accrochés à leur rocher
donc on voit apparaître une sorte
d'installation j'ai envie de dire comme
une forme de syllogisme que la
modernisation ne pourrait se faire
que sans les fonctionnaires voire contre
des fonctionnaires et les agents publics
alors même que les ressources je pense
qu'un certain nombre d audition vous
avez déjà fait 10 un peu la même chose
alors même que ces ressources existent
et elles existaient aussi déjà
il ya 20 ans
on peut citer quelques exemples je pense
notamment à toutes les compétences en
ingénierie
qui ont été largement abandonnée par
l'état et d'ailleurs ces ingénieurs de
l'état qui accompagnait souvent des
collectivités des collectivités
territoriales
font que celle ci n'avait pas été les
derniers à s'émouvoir de ces abandons de
compétences et que au delà des principes
ces abandons de compétences avait aussi
des conséquences non négligeables
finalement sur la dépense publique parce
que à leur tour les collectivités par
exemple été obligé de recourir à des
cabinets privés donc outre ces questions
politiques et budgétaires
je tiens à rappeler quelques
questions qui nous préoccupent souvent
et des questions de gouvernance qui sont
souvent trop absente du débat nous
semble-t-il
donc avant la circulaire récente du
premier ministre avant la réforme de
l'encadrement supérieur qui en en cours
de déclinaison et la création de la
direction intérêts
ministériel de l'encadrement supérieur
de l'état les compétences je l' ai déjà
dit les compétences internes existé mais
il existait aussi et
je crois qu'à un moment il faut le dire
et malheureusement des cadres de
l'administration qui était ou qui sont
sous-employés voire parfois qu'ils
étaient sans affectation
un autre
une autre part de richesse de ses
compétences et les universitaires et les
chercheurs
qui peuvent être sollicités eux aussi
pour éclairer des prises de décision et
d conduite de projets
mais l'un des autres moyens outre les
agents eux-mêmes de la conduite du genre
du changement où des transformations c
est nous semble-t-il le dialogue social
alors il ne s'agit pas d'opposer ses
moyens entre eux le recours aux cabines
et les agents eux-mêmes le dialogue
social mais nous semble-t-il que
l'objectif devrait être de l'est les
associés mieux
pour
limiter les risques et favoriser du coup
les réussites les risques d'échec lé
risque aussi de conflit les risques de
surcoût on envoie régulièrement des des
exemples donc après associer les
représentants des agents c'est peut-être
aussi un peu ce que vous faites au
partage des enjeux à la conduite du
projet de changement aux évolutions des
modes de management donner les moyens
aux représentants du personnel de monter
eux aussi en compétences parce que
finalement ça aussi ça cette campagne
sont autant nous semble-t-il d'éléments
indispensables à une co-construction
utile et aux administrations et
établissements publics c'est pas que les
administrations il ya aussi les
établissements pour mener à bien des
projets d'ordre souvent divers en tout
cas
la cfdt voit positivement
la volonté affichée de réduire le
recours aux cabinets de consultants on
voit aussi positivement la valorisation
de l'expertisé et de la compétence des
agents publics et donc on appelle de
nouveau et on voit peut-être émerger
l'avenir nous le dira une meilleure
gestion de cette richesse humaine qui
est celle de la fonction publique mais
j'ai envie de dire à ce stade soyons
prudents
il nous semble que la route est encore
longue vers une gestion du changement ou
de la modernisation ou encore de la
transformation enfants voient aussi
évoluer la terminologie sur tous ces
sujets qui
toute transformation qui ne se fasse pas
contre les agents mais bel et bien avec
eux il nous semble là aussi que
donner la parole aux agents et les
écouter et l'un des moyens les plus sûrs
de concilier un meilleur service aux
usagers parce que souvent on a tendance
à oublier cette finalité un meilleur
service aux usagers une amélioration des
conditions de travail aussi et souvent
ce sont des thématiques qui vont de pair
et pourquoi pas une réduction des coûts
en ré internalisant un certain nombre de
d'actions
alors
on peut tenter d'être aussi optimiste en
se disant qu' on est peut-être passé
mais
on assiste souvent à des vagues
successives d'un discours public qui
varient sur la fonction publique qu'on
est peut-être passé d'une espèce de de
détestation public et assumer de la
fonction publique à un besoin lui aussi
énoncé est assumée de service public sur
l'ensemble des territoires et donc ses
enjeux de transformation et d'adaptation
qui sont devant nous
doivent être nous semble-t-il au coeur
de nous de nos quotidiens en tout cas
ils ne doivent certainement plus être
l'occasion de soupçons sur les moyens
qui sont mis en oeuvre
ça c'est
le souhait qu'on formule et la
gouvernance de ces évolutions doit elle
aussi être revus et améliorés vers
davantage de transparence aussi du coup
et c'est en tout cas la conviction que
nous portons merci madame
longtemps maintenant monsieur phare est
pour l'unsa fonction publique
bon
l'accroissement du recours au
cabinet-conseil peut conduire à une
forme de privatisation de l'action
publique en effet si les pouvoirs
publics abandonnent des champs
d'expertisé entier nécessaires à
l'élaboration et la mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques ils se condamnent à
une dépendance à ces acteurs privés à
but lucratif mais aussi augmenter
l'influencé des lobbys éloigné de
l'intérêt général
indispensable à la cohésion sociale
dans certains cas les cabinets conseils
peuvent apporter une expertise qui n'est
pas encore présente mais qui est
cependant nécessaire comme par exemple
pour les procédés informatiques nouveau
lors de phases d'investissement ou de
remise à niveau mais ce ne doit être que
ponctuelle et non pas structurelle force
est de constater que le choix de recours
à ces cabinets est aussi motivée par la
possibilité qu'ils offrent de contourner
les recrutements publics et les règles
des marchés publics contre cependant un
coût très important mais qui n'est pas
du tout contrôler avec la même rigueur
que les coûts de rémunération publique
compte tenu des tensions importantes sur
les effectifs les administrations sont
rarement en mesure de pouvoir proposer
des équipes dédiées aux nouvelles
initiatives tout en maintenant
l'activité des gens place surtout depuis
la période 2007 2012 avec la rgpp les
marchés tant pluriannuel ils n'ont pas
été remis en cause lors du passage à la
mandature suivante le gema pas continuer
après la dgm eu à utiliser des marchés
de conseil et les a proposé au ministère
sous l'actuelle mandature le recours
s'est accru et les cabinets de conseil
ont été invités à proposer jusqu'à des
politiques publiques le recours aux
cabinets conseils de plus en plus
fréquent à plusieurs effet d'abord de
légitimité les compétences internes j'ai
dit de le délégitimer des légitimités
actuellement 140 millions
actuellement 140 millions d'euros en
moyenne annuelle sont censés combler des
compétences dont l'état serait dépourvu
mais dans la majorité des cas
l'administration compte tenu de sa
taille et les qualifications de ses
cadres disposent dans la réalité très
largement de ses compétences cette
situation engendre de la défiance dans
sa propre administration
par ailleurs pour conséquence de freiner
les recrutements nécessaires au maintien
d'une expertise interne comme pour toute
externalisation
il convient de disposer d'une maîtrise
d'ouvragé forte pour pouvoir les
encadrer mais même celle ci finit par
être déléguées ce qui peut conduire aux
dérives que nous constatons actuellement
si les agents qui dispose de la
compétence sont trop peu nombreux et
insuffisamment valorisé il devient
probable que les commanditaires auront
recours à une externalisation
de plus l'activité des consultants
produit une forte charge de travail pour
les cadres actifs de l'administration
qui s'ajoute à leur mission normale dans
des circonstances souvent tendu par le
manque d'effectifs ils vivent cette
intrusion comme un contournement de la
chaîne hiérarchique qui se dispense des
responsabilités qui incombent
normalement à leur encadrement reste
comme le respect d'un certain climat
social de la politesse de la
connaissance de la charge de travail de
la priorisation des actions de la
reconnaissance du maintien de l'équipe
dans la durée
par ailleurs l'encadrement supérieur
peut aussi se défausser sur les
consultants et ainsi se
déresponsabiliser ils s'appuient alors
de plus en plus souvent sur les
conclusions des rapports de ces cabinets
qui fournit jusqu'à des recommandations
politiques ce qui constitue un pouvoir
d'influencé par des organismes privés à
but lucratif cela conduit à créer des
strates supplémentaires et à renforcer
les conflits de valeurs et d'intérêt
de plus le coût du recours à ces
cabinets est exorbitant par exemple
trois jours de travail d'un consultant
sont facturés à l'état plus cher qu'un
de ses cadres de catégorie à type pour
un mois il s'agit pourtant d'agents qui
ont le même niveau de qualification et
ont souvent les mêmes diplômes par
ailleurs si la facturation correspond à
des prestations intellectuelles la
réalité du livrable correspond bien plus
à des prestations de com nication
l'impression présentation événement
outils la part intellectuelle est donc
souvent limité à titre d'exemple le
guide du télétravail publié par la dgfp
a coûté plus de 240 250 3620 euro pour 1
pour nous un coupé collé des éléments
produits par la dgafp
s'agissant de prestations elles sont
attribuées aux commanditaires maître
d'ouvragé une autre équipe de
consultants règles de tourniquets
viendra accompagner la mise en oeuvre
des orientations présentées par le
premier cabinet ce qui génère des
boucles de dépenses au profit de ces
mêmes cabinets et ce dans le but de
pérenniser leur intervention les
livrables produits à des coûts
exorbitants ont une qualité discutable
et leur utilité n'est pas toujours
avérée à l'instar du rapport sur
l'évolution du métier d'enseignant dont
le montant a tout de même de
496 1000 euros
beaucoup de consultants sont incités par
leur employeur a cherché à s'embaucher
chez le client dans une stratégie
d'essaimage nécessaires à la grh de ces
cabinets ce sont des structure très
pyramidale qui exige un important flux
de départs de cadres entre chacun des
échelons de responsabilité du cabinet
ses anciens consultants privés de
débouchés professionnels dans le cabinet
se retrouvent consolider dans des
contrats publics au sein des
administrations ou les perspectives de
carrière du moins jusqu'à la loi de 2019
était très limité les possibilités
ouvertes par cette loi permettant de
recruter des contractuels sur tous les
postes y compris le direction font
craindre que les cabinets de conseil qui
disposent d'un accès privilégié aux
décideurs et ont besoin d'alléger leurs
effectifs n'utilise ces moments pour
forcer le recrutement de certains de
leurs cadres la composition de la dgm le
gsg map des itp illustre très bien ce
phénomène
outre le recrutement d'une main d'oeuvre
à peu près inutiles l'intérêt des
cabinets temps précisément qu'ils sont à
l'extérieur de l'administration ces
anciens consultants ont tendance à
encourager le recours au cabinet et à
faire pression pour un assouplissement
des règles statutaires afin de trouver
des perspectives de même le pantouflage
de hauts fonctionnaires favorise les
conflits d'intérêts le recours aux
cabinets conseils sans la possibilité
d'encadrer leurs activités tu es peut
générer des risques juridiques ils ont
en effet accès à toutes les données que
l'état a par ailleurs besoin de
sécuriser enjeux des logiciels et aussi
de l'intelligence artificielle qui sort
de la maîtrise de son contrôle du point
de vue des agents ses interventions hors
cadre créé de la souffrance car leurs
compétences ne sont pas correctement
utilisés et ils déplorent souvent un
manque de respect de la part des
consultants qui leur sont imposées
aujourd'hui aucune règle impose aux
décideurs de soumettre au dialogue
social le recours des activités et les
impacts de l'intervention des cabinets
de conseil pour remédier à cette
situation
l'unsa fonction publique préconise de
mieux anticiper et encadré et contrôlé
le recours à ces cabinets en
internalisant l'expertisé et les
compétences en redonnant des capacités
des missions au corps de contrôle et en
développant cela surtout les versants on
pense en particulier à une filière
d'inspection et de contrôle interne
versant
en renforçant les réglementations pour
une plus grande transparence sur
l'utilisation des services de conseil en
encadrant les interventions de ses
cabinets qui ne doivent en aucun cas
devenir des donneurs d'ordre des agents
publics ni des bloqueurs d'information
d'action en obligeant les commanditaires
à la transparence sur les coûts et les
externalisations des prestations nous
proposons avant tout recours à une
prestation de conseil qu'une alternative
interne soit soigneusement examinée sur
la base de la qualité de l'optimisation
des ressources en créant des filières de
formation à des expertises nécessaires
au secteur public et en utilisant la
recherche française via des partenariats
public-public en deux temps la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique de moyens dédiés à la lutte
contre la corruption
et en tant que bonne pratique il devrait
également y avoir une consultation
complète avec les parties prenantes
concernées il faut notamment conférer
des moyens d'expression légitime est
formel représentants du personnel pour
que cette question rentre dans le cadre
du dialogue social et en conclusion pour
l'unsa le secteur public dans son
ensemble un objet très différent des
entreprises privées par conséquent un
cadre alternatif est nécessaire pour ne
pas forcer les administrations à agir
comme des entreprises l'intérêt général
est au coeur de l'action publique par la
maximisation du profit le secteur public
doit également mieux protéger les
lanceurs d'alerté et nous insistons sur
cette dernière proposition renforcer
cette protection grâce au projet de loi
en cours de discussion et à sa mise en
oeuvre je vous remercie merci monsieur
phare est maintenant pour les huit
minutes dédiées à la cgt une
intervenante où vous les parcs on fera
une intervention à devoir très bien je
vous laisse leur partition je commence à
l'état liquide continue oui nous pour
nous on va répondre quand même notre
intervention a pas mal de questions vous
avez posé
en partant de ce constat que donc nos
camarades ont fait dans leur
administration
donc déjà le premier constat c'est la
méconnaissance de bon nombre de ses
canines et sur le sens même des missions
de service public et c'est palpable
quand on les écoute par des quand un
cabinet de consultants va vous parler de
clients et pas d'administrer on n'est
déjà pas sur la même logique donc
effectivement c'est cette difficulté
cette méconnaissance amène aussi des
fois ces cabinets ne pas prendre en
compte la qualité du service rendu à
tous les administrés et on voit aussi ça
que ce soit en zone rurale ou en zone
urbaine ce qui est aussi les des
problématiques à prendre en compte donc
quand on part sur des réorganisations
d'administration ou autre ça souvent ce
n'est pas prise en compte dans ses
cabines interviennent plus dans une
logique mercantiliste qui est bien
éloigné de la notion de service public
qu'on l'a conçu après la seconde guerre
mondiale
ce n'est pas un manque de compétences en
interne mais bien un manque de personnel
dédié à ces missions qui obligeait
administration a sous traité au privé
et donc du coup ce qui fait que
certaines administrations on put rdd
département stratégique et prospective
mais bon nombre n'ont pas pu et donc
toute cette partie est sous traitée au
privé avec effectivement une
méconnaissance
du coup on se rend compte que
généralement dans l'administration
pouvait faire elle-même ce qu elle sous
traite ou privées même mieux mais faute
de moyens de tpl peut pas le faire en
revanche aucun contrôle n'est fait sur
ces marchés publics et traditions de ces
données qui sont quand même les impôts
des administrés
dont concernant la sous traitance dans
le domaine informatique
nous avons interrogé dessus
il faut quand même prendre en compte que
le domaine informatique est à
domenech de métiers sous tension
aujourd'hui et que compte tenu du faible
niveau de rémunération dans
l'administration par rapport au privé ce
que du coup il ya une tension donc une
concurrence
l'administration est normalement elle a
recruté alors sur concours déjà
ne présente pas et même en proposant des
cdi les agents ne resteront pas c'était
reconnaît qu'un cdi bien souvent vous
avez des jeunes qui sortent d'écoles qui
vont faire ça deux trois ans pour une
expérience et qui a pris pour partir
dans le privé parce que là effectivement
ils ont des perspectives de carrière
qu'ils seront meilleurs et ils auront
également un salaire qui va avec donc
ils auront plus de facilité à se
projeter fut donc ça c'était sur
l'aspect informatique
donc la première conclusion de ces
constats c'est qu'on est passé d' état
stratège a été otage de financiarisation
avec les a privées qui prennent le pas
sur l'intérêt général
et donc ça pousse quand même un petit
problème de modèle de société tel qu'on
le conçoit et de réflexion à poser sur
qu'est-ce que l'appareil de l'état et
qu'est ce qu'on veut en faire c'est
aussi la question de la puissance
publique
qui revient alors à près sur les
collectifs de travail parce que ça il
faut aussi en parler ces cabinets ont un
impact très négatif
la plupart du temps car je ne ne
rencontre pas les experts métiers dans
les administrations
ils ont tendance donc à proposer un
livrable ce que disait me suffirait de
l'unsa donc à des livrables qui sont
plusieurs communications et quand des
fois ils interrogent des experts métiers
pour voir comment amorcer une
transformation ou met en place une
nouvelle mission il ne les comprennent
pas parce qu'il ya quand même culturelle
ou alors ils ne nous écoutent pas du
tout il consulte parce que dans le
cahier des charges a marqué qu'il
fallait consulter les agents
concernant effectivement le manque de
transparence et de démocratie il est
flagrant puisque les organisations
syndicales ne sont quasiment jamais
associé à ces décisions de marché ou
autre
ça passe pas dans les instances et
souvent quand nous attend au comité
technique d'établissement aux comités
techniques ministériels on vous propose
une solution tout fini ou avant nous
n'avons pas été associés qui ont des
impacts sur la route de travail son
organisation mais aussi des missions de
l'administration
effectivement à favori contentement des
agents vous ce qui fait que les
élections syndicales on n'est pas contre
tout et pour rien il faudrait quand même
à un moment donné fixé dans la loi qu'on
soit associée
d'autant que dans certaines
administrations on interroge sur le
budget global de l'administration il
faut aussi conseil ce qui est dingue
budgétaire exactement est ce qu'on fait
de cet argent
voilà donc ça c'est une question qui
pour nous est primordial c'est
l'utilisation des fonds publics et les
impôts que paient les administrés
puisque quand on paye sans poser pour
avoir en face aussi un service public de
qualité
donc on peut juste citer un exemple qui
est flagrant aussi qu'on vend ce moment
c'est avec deux aspects un aspect
juridique à l'aspect sociologique qui
est le recours au cabinet de coaching
extérieur pour les agents de catégorie a
bien souvent donc l'administration quand
après qu'ils ont un chef de service qui
nous a pas très très bien bon maïs
disons le maître du coaching comme ça on
dira qu'on l'accompagné puis après on
pourrait le sortir c'est ça marche pas
et d'un côté sociologique aussi ça
permet aussi à certaines personnes dans
l'administration de se dire eh ben j'ai
pas le courage de dire que ça va pas de
lui dire en face et le changer de pasqua
donc ça aussi ça aussi des dérives en
interne de l'administration qui font que
ça pousse comme ur est question aussi de
décisions de pouvoirs publics et je
passais par là des films
ont cuit vous aviez mentionné l'exemple
donc du rapport sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant donc c'est 496 1800 euros
la cgt l'a appris par voie de presse et
aucun moment donné les organisations
syndicales ont été associés ou consultés
sur ce scandale nous parlons scandale
qu'un lui qui est le plus à même d'être
expert de son travail et des besoins
pour son avenir que les enseignants et
enseignantes même et que les
organisations syndicales qui les
représentent
d'ailleurs c'est enfin dans cette somme
c'est beaucoup mais c'est une goutte
d'eau dans l'océan des fonds publics
utilisés pour excuser moi le terme gaver
ses cabinets privés alors que les
suppressions d'emplois se poursuivre
dans de nombreux secteurs et des
services publics de proximité ferment
donc depuis la mise en oeuvre de la lolf
et de la réduction constante des
plafonds d'emplois les cabinets
pullulent dans le paysage des
administrations ça s'apparente à du
travail déguisé et à une délégation de
service public déguisé
la question de la déontologie et des
conflits d'intérêts ce pose également
avec le recours donc à ces cabinets qui
se partagent le gâteau d administration
et qui souvent font partie de la même
obédiences en ce sens la circulaire du
premier ministre du 19 janvier
institutionnalise l'effet tourniquet et
grave de sens pour le service public est
pour nous il ya une certaine hypocrisie
dans cette circulaire que finalement ça
admet qu'il y à des dysfonctionnements
des manques au niveau de
l'administration des manques de moyens
et que et qui effectivement en même
temps on est dans une privatisation des
fonctions de l'état une circulaire ça
n'a aucun pouvoir contraignant donc
puisque là il ya une nécessité
d'encadrer les cette dernière est même
la ve de pratiques illégales
puisque effectivement il faut rappeler
des règles simples de déontologie en
tout cas on peut les lire dans cette
circulaire la question de la sécurité
des données là qui étaient abordés tout
à l'heure elle me semble vraiment très
très importante parce qu'effectivement
ces cabinets conseils ont dans le cadre
de leur des missions qui leur sont
confiées elles ont accès à des données
vraiment sensible la plupart du temps ou
couvertes par le secret professionnel
il n'y a aucune garantie que ces données
ne soient pas réutiliser à d'autres fins
la capitalisation elle se fait à notre
sens non pas au profit des
administrations mais à celui des
cabinets conseils ces cabines et donc du
fait de leur incompréhension des
missions de service public comme donc on
lisait tout à l'heure sont un réel frein
à l'adapt ide à l'adaptabilité des
services publics qui est un principe
fondamental enfin la cgt attire
l'attention sur les comparaisons puisque
entendu
madame de montchalin par les faire des
comparaisons avec d'autres pays
européens pensent que ces comparaisons
avec l'étranger faut vraiment faire
attention puisque on n'est pas dans un
modèle de société qui est identique et
pas forcément comparable et en revanche
quand on parle de différend salarial
avec l'étranger et là les portes se
ferment et
s'il n'ya pas le même niveau de
comparaison
donc les préconisations de la cgt sur
sur ces questions s'est assuré vraiment
une
indépendance stratégique de l'état en
réintégrant au sein de toutes les
administrations des services de veille
de prospective capable de définir
interne des orientations stratégiques
pour chaque champ du service public
couvert et mener une réelle réflexion
sur ce qui est l'appareil d'état et les
moyens qui doit lui être alloués et
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs à la cgt
fonction publique qu'on mène toute une
campagne qu'on appelle 10 % à 10 % en
plus d'emplois 10% en plus de salaire
de réduction de temps de travail et je
pense qu'effectivement là l'enjeu est
effectivement des du renforcement de la
fonction publique pour l'intérêt général
elle est centrale dans dans cette
commission denquête merci beaucoup
[Musique]